In the previous video we learn what
collinear points are In this video all we have to do is
visualize points lines and
planes if we have three points a b and s which
have exactly one line passing through all
of them then they are called collinear the
correct  The definition says that three and more
points are collinear if a line passes through each
of them Now consider the three points p and a since we do not have
one line that can
pass through each of the points they are non
collinear but there is something special  You Need to Know About
Three Non Collinear Points
Exactly One Plane Will Pass Through All Three
of Them It Doesn't Matter Where the Points Lie
Only One Plane Will Pass Through Any Three Non
Collinear Points Now Consider This
Table That Has a Plane
Surface on Top Zoom  We have four points p and
s on it basically points p and s lie
on a plane what do we call the
points that lie on one plane they are called coplanar
points
remember three points will always be coplane
four and more  Points May and May Not Be
Coplanar Planar Means on One Plane and Co Means Together
So I Four and More Points Together
Form a Plane They Are Called
Coplanar Points This is
a Line and a Point Which is
Not on It Think About It  Will they lie on one
plane yes these too will also form
exactly one plane like this Now we come to
the last concept in this
video ajum we have a plane like this and we have two lines
line l and line m lying
on it taking a guess  What would you call
lines l and m yes as they lie on one plane they will be called co
planar
lines so if we have a plane and two lines from
line l and line m coming on it then
lines l and m are called co planar lines
But two lines are always co planar no not
necessarily this is a plane surface and line
A lies on it they can be another line O which passes through
the plane and does not lie on it
in such true cases Lines A and O are called non co
planar  Lines as Both of Them Do Not Lie
on One
[Music]
Plane